russia consistently denies that intends
to invade ukraine but there is a great
amount of skepticism about just what
these military exercises are for
in crimea the territory illegally
annexed by russia in 2014. satellite
images have identified more than 500
russian military tents and hundreds of
vehicles at an abandoned airfield there
to the north of ukraine as many as 30
000 russian troops are now in belarus
for a 10-day military exercise just a
few hours away from kiev and here we can
see some of those military personnel
less than 15 miles from the border with
ukraine there are even more russian
forces on ukraine's eastern border
adding to concern these exercises could
be being used as a cover for invasion
this image shows a large deployment of
troops that recently arrived at the
cursed training area around 70 miles
from ukraine's border
now russia's military could very quickly
overwhelm ukraine and it's estimated up
to 50 000 civilians could be killed or
wounded in the event of an invasion
a u.s intelligence report has identified
nine different possible routes into the
country for russian forces
one possible scenario is that russia
could easily take eastern ukraine via
crimea which is home to around half of
ukraine's military including their most
capable units let's take a look now at
nato's activity ukraine is not a member
of that defensive alliance but nato
forces are bolstering their presence in
member countries on ukraine's western
border
nato air power including raf jets have
been flying missions close to russian
assets one theory is they're trying to
intercept russian communications let's
take a look at some of the flights from
january the 25th
two aircraft were spotted along the
coastline of crimea one was deployed
from a u.s air base in sicily the other
a british jet from raf waddington in
lincolnshire
three maritime patrol aircraft also got
airborne from raf lossy mouth in
scotland one spent five hours circling a
position where the baltic and north seas
meet russian naval vessels were believed
to be operating nearby there is a lot of
theaters surrounding this crisis and all
eyes are on the movement of russian
troops while this large military
exercise continues to inflame tensions
in the region